[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro des matins du
sénat les missions qui vous fait vivre
les travaux des sénateurs le budget 2021
arrive au sénat les sénateurs commencent
leurs auditions pour préparer l'examen
du projet de loi de finances et ce matin
nous allons parler du budget de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
un budget en hausse et les sénateurs ont
auditionné la ministre concerne ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche frédéric vidal je vous laisse
écouter son audition l'examen du projet
de loi de finances nous réunir pour
échanger débattre des grandes
orientations de la mission
interministérielle recherché
enseignement supérieur
il s'agit du quatrième budget que j'ai
l'honneur de vous présenter mais il se
distingue des précédents tant il
intervient dans un contexte inédit
inédit évidemment en raison de la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons mais aussi
des crises économiques et sociales qui
en découlent et qui appelle une
mobilisation sans précédent de la part
de l'ensemble dû gouvernement et la
mairesse troisième budget de l'état au
remboursement de la dette participe
pleinement de cette mobilisation inédite
ce budget aussi car il intervient au
moment de l'examen parlementaire de la
loi de programmation pour la recherche
dont vous débattre et en séance publique
la semaine prochaine et qui prévoit un
réinvestissement de 25 milliards d'euros
sur les dix prochaines années
il n'est dit enfin car on ne peut parler
de savoirs et de connaissances
d'ambition pour nos enseignants
chercheurs et nos étudiants sans songer
au drame terrible qui vendredi dernier a
endeuillé la france toute entière
c'est pourquoi je tiens en préambule a
adressé un message de soutien et
d'espoir à l'ensemble de la communauté
des enseignants de la république et leur
dire que mon ministère sera toujours à
leurs côtés
ce contexte inédit appelé des réponses
inédites et c'est pourquoi je suis fier
de vous présenter cette année un budget
à la fois renforcer ambitieux et
résolument tourné vers l'avenir
les mesures exceptionnelles ont d'ores
et déjà été prises pour faire face à la
crise avec 3 loi de finances
rectificative votée entre le mois de
mars et le mois de juillet
2020 vous avez aussi d'ailleurs souligné
dans le rapport que le groupe de travail
recherche du sénat a produit en juin
dernier avec quelle réactivité et quel
talent nos chercheurs se sont mobilisés
pendant cette crise
certains de ces projets s'inscrivent
désormais dans le moyen et le long terme
et bien sûr nous poursuivront leur
soutien en 2021 et et au delà pour
l'exercice 2001 21 un soutien massif et
donc apporter à notre recherche à nos
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et à tous ceux qui chaque jour ils
étudient et y travaillent qui se traduit
sur les trois programmes budgétaires de
mon ministère par une hausse de 600
millions d'euros par rapport à 2020 et
par 700 recrutements nets dans les
établissements de recherche et
l'enseignement supérieur à 7 euros
s'ajouteront bien évidemment les
financements issus du plan de relance et
du programme d'investissements d'avenir
particulièrement important s'agissant du
ministère et sur lesquelles je
reviendrai brièvement l'obligé 2021
repose sur trois grandes priorités
un réinvestissement historique dans la
recherche tout d'abord suivant la
trajectoire fixée par la future loi de
programmation pour la recherche le
soutien et le renforcement des moyens
dédiés aux établissements d'enseignement
supérieur avec une attention toute
particulière portée aux personnels
auxquels je tiens et si à rendre hommage
puisqu'il s'occupe merveilleusement de
nos étudiants dans ses rangs très
difficile enfin dans le cadre de la
crise sanitaire la priorité absolue a
été donnée à la vie étudiante et à la
lutte contre la précarité sous toutes
ses formes et je voulais vous assurer
que nous ferons en sorte qu'aucun
étudiant ne soit laissé sur le bord de
la route c'est tout l'objet de
l'engagement du premier ministre
concernant notamment la mise en place
récente de cette prime de 150 euros pour
l'ensemble des étudiants boursiers et
des jeunes percevant les apl une mesure
dont bien sûr je me félicite le budget
pour 2021 traduit donc tout d'abord
l'engagement de mon ministère pour
réarmer la recherche française et lui
permettre de retrouver son ambition et
son attractivité
c'est la première marche du
réinvestissement que prévoit la loi de
programmation de recherche qui est
présenté dans le cadre de ce projet de
loi de finances
très concrètement des dom et 21 c dont
400 millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
abonderont le budget de la recherche
225 millions consacrés au programme 172
recherche scientifique et technologique
pluridisciplinaire et 165 millions sur
le programme 150 formations supérieur et
recherche universitaire 10 millions de
crédits nouveaux sont enfin prévu pour
le programme 193 recherche spatiale
une fois pris en compte les évolutions
tendancielles et du périmètre sur
lesquelles je reviendrai
s'agissant de la répartition des emplois
315 concerne le programme 172 et 385 le
programme 150 cette loi de programmation
pour la recherche
je vous en ai parlé avait aussi vocation
à engager un vaste mouvement de
revalorisation des carrières et des
rémunérations pour l'ensemble des
personnels de la recherche c'est
pourquoi dès le budget 2010 21 130
millions d'euros
ils seront consacrés ces revalorisations
se traduiront par une augmentation des
primes de l'ensemble des personnels
qu'ils soient fonctionnaires
contractuels sous statut de droit public
ou de droit privé qu'ils travaillent au
sein des organismes de recherche ou au
sein des universités
elle se garantir ont aussi que tous les
jeunes chercheurs soient recrutés à au
moins deux smic
je suis d'ailleurs très heureuse que ces
revalorisations ait pu faire l'objet du
premier accord majoritaire de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui a été signé le 12 octobre
à matignon en présence du premier
ministre à l'issue de plusieurs semaines
de discussions extrêmement riche avec
les organisations syndicales dont je
tiens à saluer l'engagement et le
sérieux ce protocole permet de préciser
deux grandes séries de mesures d'une
part le schéma des revalorisations et
d'autre part des mesures propres
évolutions de carrière
différentes catégories ce qu'on appelle
re pyramide âge décor pour les
enseignants-chercheurs dégrade pour les
chercheurs et par catégories d'emploi
pour les i trf soutenir nos chercheurs
et nos personnels c'est aussi bien
évidemment soutenir nos doctorants c'est
pourquoi des 2 mai 21 6 millions d'euros
supplémentaires seront destinés aux
étudiants qui s'engageront dans une
thèse à terme nous visons une
augmentation de 20% du nombre de thèses
financées par l'état et une augmentation
de 30 % des rémunérations de ses thèses
le soutien au personnel et aux jeunes
chercheurs s'accompagne aussi d'un
soutien sans faille aux établissements
qu'ils animent
c'est pourquoi 150 millions d'euros
conforteront le budget des universités
et des organismes de recherche pour
garantir la soutenabilité des
recrutements augmenté de 10% la notation
de base des laboratoires dès 2021 et
garantir que tous les nouveaux
chercheurs recrutés puissent bénéficier
d'une dotation de démarrage de 10000
euros pour amorcer leurs projets de
recherche dans de bonnes conditions
l'autre pilier de la stratégie de la
recherche française celle agence
nationale de la recherche dont le budget
sera réhaussé de 149 millions d'euros en
autorisations d'engagement
ce montant sera démultiplié par le plan
de relance qui apportera 250 millions
d'euros supplémentaires faisant passer
les moyens de la nr dès l'année
prochaine
faisant augmenter les moyens de la rd
l'année prochaine de 400 millions
d'euros de façon à atteindre dès l'année
prochaine un taux de sélection de 23%
enfin il est également indispensable et
là encore la crise que nous traversons
nous le rappelle de renforcer les liens
entre la science et la société
notre recherche doit aller au devant de
nos concitoyens c'est pourquoi 20
millions de crédits supplémentaires
seront consacrés à cette ouverture de la
science vers la verna société le
deuxième grand pilier structurant de la
mairesse pour 2021 et celui de
l'enseignement supérieur
mais aussi particulièrement touché par
la crise
on a souvent dit à ces dernières
semaines que l'investissement dans la
recherche se faisait au détriment de
l'enseignement supérieur telle évidence
un faux procès puisque mon ministère
poursuit son engagement résolu et massif
dans l'enseignement supérieur comme il
le fait depuis 2018 avec l'adoption du
plan étudiants c'est déjà 480 millions
d'euros supplémentaires qui ont été
investis dans ce cadre depuis trois ans
et ce projet de loi de finances ouvre 81
millions d'euros supplémentaires à
destination de l'enseignement supérieur
qui s'ajoutent aux 165 millions de
crédits ouverts dans le cadre de la
recherche c'est 80 millions
correspondent en réalité à une
augmentation de près de 100 millions des
moyens des établissements puisque un
ajustement à la baisse d'une vingtaine
de millions d'euros sur des besoins
immobiliers s'est opérée l'enveloppent
dédié à la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments de l'état une enveloppe de
près de 4 milliards d'euros
nous permettant d'absorber ces 20
millions cet investissement permettra de
poursuivre la mise en oeuvre de la loi
orientation et réussite des étudiants de
d'augmenter encore les créations de
places dans les filières en tension et
permettra une allocation des moyens un
mieux ciblées vers les établissements le
plan étudiants à d'ores et déjà permis
de créer trente neuf mille places depuis
2017 et ses moyens supplémentaires
permettront aussi de poursuivre la mise
en place de la réforme des études de
santé
nous renforçons donc l'engagement du
gouvernement en faveur de la réussite et
nous dépasserons l'objectif de 500
millions d'euros de moyens nouveaux que
nous avions fixé ce financement
permettront aussi dès l'année prochaine
d'étendre le stratégique à l'ensemble
des établissements de plus de 500
étudiants 15 millions d'euros seront
aussi destinée à financer le coût des
mesures du protocole parcours
professionnel carrière et rémunérations
et enfin 9 millions d'euros seront
ajoutées en faveur de l'enseignement
supérieur privé notamment dspg pour une
meilleure prise en compte
la progression de la démographie
étudiante et une revalorisation du
montant moyen de la subvention par
l'étudiant dans ce cadre le plan de
relance qui concerne en fait l'ensemble
des champs couverts par mon ministère
permettra d'ajouter au budget que je
viens de détail et 95 millions d'euros
dès 2021 60 millions d'euros pour
financer la mise en oeuvre du plan un
jeune une solution avec des créations de
place notamment dans les formations
paramédicales de santé formations
courtes pour amortir les effets de la
crise sanitaire et accueillir la
diversité des nouveaux bacheliers et 35
millions d'euros seront consacrés à la
transformation pédagogique et numérique
la période que nous traversons appelle
également un investissement sans
précédent en faveur de la vie étudiante
je l' ai déjà dit nos étudiants sont
particulièrement fragilisé par cette
crise et notre responsabilité est de
faire en sorte qu' aucun ne soit entravé
paix réaliser ou exclus par cette crise
c'est pourquoi les moyens consacrés à la
vie étudiante sont en hausse de 134
millions d'euros par rapport à 2020 2 3
milliards d'euros sont consacrés aux
aides directes aux étudiants à la
rentrée 2020 les montants des bourses
sur critères sociaux ont été réévalués
pour la deuxième année consécutive et
tiennent compte pour la première fois de
l'inflation avec l'augmentation
prévisionnelle du nombre de boursiers
c'est un engagement financier de plus de
80 millions d'euros qui est pris pour
les étudiants boursiers sur critères
sociaux
de la même façon que l'an dernier pour
aider les étudiants à préparer leur
entrée la première mensualité de bourse
a été versée avant le 31 août pour les
dossiers complets à ces mesures viennent
s'ajouter des dispositifs d'une ampleur
historique
le ticket de restauration universitaire
à 1 euro pour tous les étudiants
boursiers avec un financement prévu de
50 millions d'euros pour lutter contre
la précarité alimentaire et aider les
familles et les étudiants revenus les
plus faibles en leur permettant
d'accéder un repas complet
libre et de qualité pour un prix
extrêmement réduites grâce à la
contribution de l'état
je tiens aussi à signaler que le plan
france relance prévoit de renforcer la
garantie des prêts étudiants permettant
à 60 mille bénéficiaires potentiels de
pouvoir bénéficier de ces prêts garantis
par l'état
les autres programmes de la mairesse qui
ne relèvent pas du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur voient leurs
crédits évoluer uniquement du fait de
mesures de périmètre cette diminution
purement faciale n'a aucun impact sur le
niveau d'ambition des autres ministères
au sein de la mairesse je voudrais noter
en particulier la baisse des crédits
affectés à la recherche spatiale qui
relève désormais de mon collègue bruno
le maire qui reflète la fin du
remboursement de la dette à lézat ou
encore le transfert du programme
recherche culturelle et culture
scientifique sur la mission culture
l'ensemble des financements du plan de
relance représente plus de 6 5 milliards
d'euros pour mon ministère à la fois
dans le cadre du plan de relance et dans
le cadre du pays à 4 et je voudrais
conclure là dessus en plus des mesures
que j'ai déjà mentionné
cela nous permettra d'enclencher des
stratégies d'accélération de financer
les éco systèmes d'enseignement
supérieur de recherche ou d'innovation
de soutenir l'emploi dans la recherche
le développement et je me félicite de
cet investissement massif du plan de
relance en faveur de ce ministère ce qui
traduit la priorité du gouvernement pour
la recherche l'innovation et
l'enseignement supérieur au service de
la relance
voilà mesdames les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs ce budget vous le voyez
traduit la priorité donnée par ce
gouvernement à la recherche et à
l'enseignement supérieur renforcer sur
l'ensemble de ces volets la mairesse
permet à notre recherche de faire face
aux grands défis de demain de continuer
le combat contre la crevette 19 de
renforcer notre enseignement supérieur
en créant de nouvelles places partout
sur le territoire et en investissement
d'avant investissant davantage dans le
numérique et l'innovation ou encore la
rénovation des bâtiments universitaires
je vous remercie pour votre attention
et remercie madame amis donc au juge au
début d'autres réunions j'ai donc
d'abord donné la parole à doom 2
rapporteur pour avis de la mission est
donc d'abord pour la recherche leur
darcos merci beaucoup malamani se désole
de n'avoir pas entendu votre début de
mai le sénat ne finira jamais de nous
étonner on devait pas pouvoir voter
avant 45 pour les juges pour la
république c'est pour ça que on est
arrivés tous en retard
madame la ministre le projet loi de
finances donc pour 2021 intègre donc la
première étape de revalorisation des
rémunérations et des carrières des
personnels de la recherche vous l'avez
dit grâce au protocole que vous avez
signé il ya maintenant une dizaine de
jours et je vous en félicite
mais ces mesures auront vignes
inévitablement une incidence sur le
disney vieillesse technicité cnis cité
le gvt
aujourd'hui supporté par les
établissements de recherche ce qui
grèvent leurs marges de manoeuvre
budgétaires ce problème structurel n'est
pas abordée par la loi programmation
recherche donc je m'interroge sont vos
intentions en la matière je pose mes
deux trois questions comme ça sera plus
simple une augmentation de 10% la
dotation de base et laboratoires de
recherche est prévue l'année prochaine
quel montant exact cela représente il
voulait peut-être dit mais je ne l'est
pas je n'ai pas noté
comment cette augmentation s'articulera
tel avec le préciput nouvelle formule
qui comme vous l'avait indiqué lors de
votre audition sur la voie programmation
doit aussi permettre d'abonder ses
laboratoires
troisième question le projet des
finances pour 2021 prévoit de consacrer
20 millions d'euros à l'ouverture de la
science vers la société et au
développement de la culture scientifique
comment ce montant et il fléché est ce
que ce n'est que par la nerfs comme vous
me l'aviez
10 précédemment ou est ce que dans le
projet de loi il ya un fléchage
spécifique également sachant que vous
partagez ce budget avec la culture ce
qui est jamais très simple pour
universcience notamment merci ministre
merci beaucoup
madame et rapporteur donc effectivement
à la question du gvt est une question
récurrente et celui ci n'est plus
compensée automatiquement depuis déjà de
nombreuses années ce qui a posé beaucoup
de problèmes aux établissements il est
prévu dans le budget 51 millions d'euros
consacrés à la soutenabilité et donc
voilà ça nous permet d'avoir dans le
cadre du dialogue de gestion un
véritable accompagnement des
établissements et il est aussi prévu 60
millions d'euros pour aider le cnrs à
franchir ce qu'on appelle le mur le mur
du cnrs c'est si je puis dire
les dotations de base des laboratoires
seront amendés de 30 millions d'euros
pardon et la dernière votre dernière
question en fait le on ne partage pas le
budget avec la culture si je puis dire
en fait ce qui est prévu c'est que il y
est c'est dans le cadre du projet de loi
un pour cent des projets anr du montant
des projets à l'air qu'ils soient
consacrés à la culture c'est ce qui nous
permet d'atteindre ces 20 millions
d'euros dédié spécifiquement à
l'accompagnement
alors là là là les questionnements site
unique c'est une compétence partagée
voilà donc c'est la scène nous
travaillons avec le ministère de la
culture merci monsieur pieds-noirs
n'importe où alors c'est mon supérieur
merci monsieur le président dans le
ministre merci pour votre présentation à
dans le flot des des chiffres on
al'occasion évident de regarder ça en
détail devraient vous interroger sur sur
quatre points en particulier assez assez
pratico pratique en fait vous avez
évoqué la lutte contre la précarité des
étudiants
vous le savez que depuis le début de la
crise les crous se sont très sollicités
et trop très mobilisée pour venir en
aide aux étudiants qui ont été en
difficulté avec le confinement et des
avances de trésorerie dans ton permis au
crous de 20,2 de tenir le coup de rester
à flot si je puis dire mais c'est
sérieux de trésorerie ne résolvent pas
le problème des pertes d'exploitation de
location bien sûr qu'ils aient qui selon
les projections pourraient atteindre
jusqu'à 200 millions d'euros
qu'en est il de la compensation par
l'état de ceux de ce manque à gagner
vous n'avez pas évoqué en revanche les
répercussions de la crise sanitaire sur
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers dans
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur en termes de mobilité tout le
monde sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement compliqué pouvez vous nous
dire à combien se chiffrera la baisse
des effectifs à la rentrée avec des
projections en termes de pertes
financières pour les établissements qui
en découlent sur rance et bien dans ta
modèle économique repose beaucoup à dire
essentiellement mais beaucoup sur
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers
troisième point c'est un peu une marotte
de notre commission la transparence sur
la cv aussi à contribution de vie
étudiante de campus est ce que vous
pourriez de dresser un rapide état des
lieux de l'utilisation croit savoir
qu'elle a été largement sollicités au
moment du confinement également pour
développer des actions notamment en
termes de numérique et puis dernier
point sur la rénovation du du bâti il ya
une enveloppe de 3 milliards 7 me
semble-t-il globalement pour la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
nationaux
est ce qu'on peut avoir une idée de ce
que ça va représenter pour les bâtiments
universitaires et selon quels critères
seraient seraient attribués les aides
pour la rénovation de ses bâtiments
je remercie la ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
alors concernant le crous le total des
surcoûts estimés à ce jour sont enfin
deux pas de surcoût de pertes
d'exploitation en version de 147,5
millions d'euros une partie de la prise
en charge des pertes d'exploitation a
déjà été votée dans le père fr3 et le
restera en gestion dans le plfr 4
évidemment hors de question qu'on
abandonne le réseau des heures qui a été
absolument essentiel pendant pendant
cette période
en ce qui concerne les étudiants
internationaux
en réalité nous n'avons pas vu de baisse
massive du nombre d'inscriptions on est
même sur un tout petit plus quelques
pourcents par contre nous avons vu une
baisse de la présence des étudiants et
là on est aux alentours de 30% de baisse
de la mobilité physique
c'était une véritable inquiétude porté
par les grandes écoles et les écoles qui
effectivement est un modèle économique
fondé sur les droits d'inscription des
étudiants internationaux et c'est
pourquoi les étudiants ont été notamment
considérés comme des publics
prioritaires pour la délivrance des
visas parce que c'était ça qui les
inquiétait le plus et donc la situation
a été débloquée au début du mois d'août
les étudiants étant considérés comme
prioritaires et les visas ayant été
délivré
même si les étudiants ne se sont pas
déplacés physiquement en france de
manière à ce qu'ils soient sûrs de
pouvoir et venir au moment où les
conditions sanitaires le permettront en
ce qui concerne la
la cdc il y à une partie vous savez qui
reste au niveau des crous et qui leur
permet d'accompagner d'accompagner les
étudiants
le reste est distribué aux univers est
reçu par les universités c'est la
création par exemple de 26 maisons de
santé qui sont actuellement présentes
dans les établissements et qui
permettent aux étudiants d'avoir accès
non seulement à des médecins
généralistes mais des spécialistes par
rotation de 2000 journée c'est plus de
20 millions d'euros qui ont été
effectivement utilisé au moment du
confinement soit pour des aides directes
aux étudiants soit pour des achats et
des prêts d'ordinateurs des clés 4g de
l'aide alimentaire etc et nous avons
demandé une inspection de nous faire un
rapport sur l'usagé de la cvs puisque ça
fait maintenant trois 3 rentrée que la
cvc a été mise à disposition d des
établissements en ce qui concerne la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
effectivement ces 3 2 7 milliards
d'euros qui sont prévues le parc es r si
je puis dire représente à peu près 40%
du parc de l'état donc voilà c'est ce
qu'on peut c'est ce qu'on peut imaginer
en réalité les dossiers sont
actuellement en cours d'instruction ce
qui est très important c'est que pour
participer au plan de relance il faut
effectivement que les projets soient
suffisamment mûrs mais nous avons d'ores
et déjà reçu pour plus de 3 milliards
d'euros de demandes de financement
donc je ne doute pas que nous aurons
consommer les environ 40% qui qui sont
prévues il faut penser aussi que
beaucoup de ces projets étaient aussi en
préparation pour les contrats de plan
état région et donc que ce sera
évidemment un complément à ce qui sera
dans le cadre des contrats de plan état
région là tout et tout est remonté donc
c'est les projets ont été montés le 9
octobre il
actuellement en cours d'instruction nous
avons entendu notre reporter qui ont
posé ils ont posé des questions va donc
que donne la parole aux représentants
des groupes qui sont présents et qui ont
demandé la parole monsieur ozu gaza
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues madame les ministres moi je
voudrais commencer par un 1.2 méthode
qui fait que notre commission à peine
renouveler doit d'arrache-pied s'atteler
à l'analyse de layle ppr et dans le même
temps de la loi de finances 2021 avec
par ailleurs un exercice difficile qui
est qu' il faut absolument que la loi de
programmation budgétaire soit votée avec
avant le budget 2021 parce que 2021
c'est la première année de la halle ppr
mais les circonstances font que il va se
passer quelques semaines entre les entre
les deux événements ce qui n'est pas
absolument simple à comprendre notamment
quand on sait que la partie recettes du
même budget a déjà été votée par
l'assemblée nationale et on sent que la
marge de possibilité laissée au sénat
est réduite par cette conjonction
calendaire qui nous est peu favorable
donc je voulais commencer par par ce
point de point de méthodes
je voulais aussi reprendre le constat
réalisé par mon collègue le sénateur
pieds noirs nous nous avions travaillé
avec lui sur les difficultés qu'avait eu
les universités à faire face à la crise
du duduk au vide
cet été et au au printemps les
universités ont dépensé beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup d'argent pour aider
les étudiants elle ne le regrette pas je
ne le regrette pas c'était une nécessité
absolue elles se sont aperçus et nous
l'ont dit qu' ils ont découvert à cette
occasion que fournir un ordinateur à
chaque étudiant ce n'était pas un luxe
que c'était une nécessité absolue et
c'est des choses auxquelles
malheureusement il n'avait pas pensé
avant la crise la crise pandémique à 7 à
cette grave crise pandémique s'ajoutent
les cinquante cinq mille étudiants
supplémentaires qui pèse lourdement sur
les finances des universités hors
j'observe objectivement que votre budget
s'inscrit peu ou prou dans la
trajectoire qui a été défini par la loi
de 2008 sur la programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2010
8 2022 c'est à peu près la même
trajectoire
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas de prise
en compte à la fois de la crise
pandémique d'une part et de
l'augmentation forte du nombre
d'étudiants
ce qui fait et que je les regrette l an
passé je le regrette de nouveau mais
encore cette année comme tous les ans
depuis dix ans leur le ratio budgétaire
par étudiant va baisser ce qui est un
très mauvais signal envoyé à la fois aux
étudiants et aussi à la nation parce que
je crois que dans les circonstances
actuelles c'était important de montrer
qu'il y avait une priorité politique
pour pour accueillir les étudiants jeu
je regrette profondément
l'augmentation
qui suit à peu près la même trajectoire
du nombre de contractuels dans
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
entre 2010 et 2017 c'est + 14% et j'ai
du mal à comprendre que dans dans la loi
de programmation de la recherche on met
à la disposition des établissements de
nouveaux outils leur permettant
d'accroître cette précarité
aujourd'hui il faut le dire si les
universités ont tenu le coup face aux
énormes difficultés que l'on connaît
c'est grâce à tous ces contractuels qui
se sont mobilisés pour continuer à
assurer le service public et je crois
que la moindre des choses c'est
aujourd'hui de leur offrir un peu plus
de postes statutaires c'est à dire des
conditions de travail un peu plus
sereine et un confort individuel
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'ont plus et je
trouve que c'est catastrophique pour
l'image que nous donnons dans la nation
aux métiers de la science je crois que
ça fait partie de la revalorisation que
vous souhaitez que nous souhaitons que
de leur offrir des postes de titulaires
je suis intimement persuadé que c'est
aussi de cette façon que à la fois nous
empêcherons la fuite des cerveaux mais
que nous ramènerons en france des
cerveaux français ou étrangers qui sont
partis et qui aujourd'hui trouve que
dans le système français il ya quelque
chose qui est très précieux c7
cette stabilité cette liberté qui est
donné aux chercheurs statutaires qui n'a
pas besoin de courir après les contrats
en permanence comme c'est le cas
ailleurs à l'étranger
je vous donne juste un exemple au cnrs
la baisse il ya une baisse cette année
de nouveaux d'emplois statutaires
il ya 41 emplois sous plafond statutaire
qui disparaissent donc là aussi c'est un
très mauvais un très mauvais signal quai
qui est envoyé et enfin je veux pas être
trop long mais je veux
évoquer la continuation des contrats
doctoraux c'est à dire tous ces
étudiants en doctorat qui n'ont pu mener
du fait de la crise sanitaire
leurs travaux soit qu'ils étaient privés
de leur laboratoire des bibliothèques
voire même de leurs chantiers à
l'étranger et qui aujourd'hui sont dans
la tente d'un financement
alors je sais que en ile de france la
région la région ile de france a apporté
un financement conséquent pour permettre
la prolongation de ses contrats
doctoraux ce que j'aimerais savoir c'est
est ce que dans les autres régions
françaises
les régions ont apporté le même le même
financement sur je vous dis j'en finis
là sur la compensation du gvt
bon j'ai pas bien compris la
démonstration mais l'avantagé c'est que
comme on va continuer à travailler avec
vous dans le cas de la lpp rrl rlx parlé
une nouvelle fois du budget 21e 2021 je
vous proposerai là la question ancien pc
monsieur ps veut tout progrès ne vous
sentez pas obligé de faire court comme
ce matin après l'intérêt sur longue de
monsieur groupe et reste prête attention
le plan social est vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président vous savez
j'ai toujours droit au but comme mon
équipe de foot préférée et j'aurai une
seule question madame la ministre je ne
voudrais pas voilà j'ai déjà eu pas mal
de réponses à mes questions dans les
dernières heures suite aux différentes
interventions que j'ai pu un échange que
j'ai pu avoir avec elle madame le
ministre prenne la république avait
promis de construire 60 mille logements
étudiants supplémentaires au cours du
quinquennat
nous savons maintenant que cela sera
plutôt entre 30 et 35 milles logements
étudiants d'ici 2022 qu'en est il sur
cette question du logement étudiant
je vous remercie monsieur schneider oui
madame amis je vais pas posé de
questions très techniques sur le budget
puisqu'on découvre
étant plutôt novice ou simplement vous
parlez des des nouveaux posts pas de
d'étudiants dans le domaine de la santé
je voulais savoir s'il y avait une
réflexion qui a été menée sur justement
tous les des organismes privés qui sont
obligé d'accompagner les étudiants qui
sont en première année de médecine ou et
on voit même maintenant pour les pour
les infirmières et qui crée quand même
maintenant une grande inégalité dans
l'accès à ces concours
auparavant il ya ces filières voir si on
avait des statistiques sur le nombre
d'élèves d'étudiants qui réussissent
sans avoir du soutien comme ça privé
rémunéré donc par leurs familles
lorsqu'elles le peuvent et de la
deuxième question si c'est ça va sur
cette politique des grands sites
on vous parle est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui se fait bien en concertation
avec les collectivités territoriales et
comment au conçoit ses grands sites pour
qu'on aille pas mary une ghettoïsation
presque de certaines
spécialité ou recherche puisqu'on sait
qu'au contraire le brassage
intellectuelle et culturelle participe
justement à l'excellence de la fois de
la recherche et de l'enseignement
supérieur
c'est monsieur le rejeton
[Musique]
merci moi aussi je remercie mme la
ministre merci monsieur le président moi
aussi je vais aller droit au but même si
c'est pas pour le coup comme sénateur de
paris mon équipe favorite mais je vais
essayer d'être chez sidel bref quand
même c'était pour vous détendre un peu
une question sur la précarité étudiante
vous avez évoqué l'europe à 1 euro le
gouvernement a fait le choix que je
partage de cibler les aides ciblées
notamment pour ses étudiants boursiers
ceux qui sont le plus en difficulté et
je vois que ce qui avait été décidé pour
2020 est reconduit en 2021 c'est à dire
le repas un euro une bonne mesure il y à
t'il comme on sait qu'une population qui
est de plus en plus isolé avec la crise
du coc vie qui est de plus en plus en
difficulté à cause de crise aussi y at
il d'autres mesures sociable social
pardon envisageable pour les étudiants
qui en ont le plus besoin qui serait
possible dans le budget de l'an prochain
c est ce qu est ce qu il yad autres
interventions qu'on administre répondent
oui madame bride un peu après
l'intervention de la brûler si vous êtes
d'accord madame ici de vous répondre et
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous avez évoqué dans votre
trait ambühl les la réforme des études
de santé qui étaient prises en compte
dans le plf j'aurais voulu avoir
davantage de précisions
concrètement combien d'étudiants
supplémentaires pourront nous accueillir
j'ai pas besoin de développer ici
j'imagine sur la nécessité d'accroître
considérablement nos capacités au regard
de ce qui se passe notamment dans le
secteur hospitalier mais on pourrait
aussi évoquer la médecine de ville et
comment 30 on en compte les réalités
régionales dans l'augmentation de ses
capacités je vais citer la normandie
mais je pourrais évidemment citer bien
d'autres régions
les années passent et se sont traduites
par lorsqu'il y avait une augmentation
du numerus clausus zéro augmentation en
normandie et l'année dernière année
faste trois étudiants supplémentaires ce
qui évidemment très loin du compte pour
enrayer la désertification médicale que
nous connaissons dans notre région mais
qui est aussi qui existent aussi
ailleurs
évidemment former les jeunes en région
ne garantit pas de tout mais permet
quand même qu'ils s'y installent plus
probablement et donc ça me semble utile
d'avoir ce regard là et puis autre
question sur les contrats de plan ou de
projets je crois on dit maintenant est à
région parce que vous les avez
brièvement évoquée mais je voudrais
avoir des précisions là aussi en termes
d'articulation entre ccp er et le plan
de relance parce que vous avez évoquées
à l'instant notamment en termes de de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments des
crédits si j'ai bien compris qui
passerait des cpe air plutôt aux plans
de relance ou l' inverse sera donc ça
mérite précision si je n'ai pas compris
en tout cas pour être tout à fait clair
je voudrais exprimer une crainte c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de recyclage de l'un
au profit de l'autre on sait vous le
savez particulièrement que ccpr
permettent
ben des politiques en matière
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
en région
parce que les régions précisément
s'impliquent fortement et mais qu'on a
besoin que l'état continue de s'y
impliquer aux côtés de dérision si vos
dogmes la ministre pour commencer je
vais reprendre dans l'ordre des
interventions si vous voulez bien
monsieur sénateurs ouzoulias si il y a
en fait 180 millions d'euros
supplémentaires prévus dans le cadre du
plan de relance pour la création de
places 60 millions d'euros qui sont déjà
débloqués sur l'année 2020 en avance de
gestion si je puis dire ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que l'immense majorité
des demandes se portait notamment sur
les filières paramédicales et que donc
nous avons travaillé avec les régions
qui normalement finance les ifsi et donc
nous avons contribué financièrement à
l'augmentation très importante de place
par exemple dans les ici et de façon
générale dans les formations
paramédicales
nous avons aussi contribué à une
ouverture plus importante de formation
de type bac + en entamant par le cnam
parce que nous avions cette année
beaucoup de bacheliers professionnels
qui n'avait pas forcément envie de
poursuivre des études pendant très
longtemps mais qui simplement vu la
conjoncture n'ont pas pu être embauchés
donc nous avons aussi favorisé pour ces
bacheliers qui le souhaitaient des
formations complémentaires d'intérêt
local
là aussi en lien très étroit avec avec
les régions donc voilà c'est un travail
qui a été qui a été menée de manière à
ce que l'on puisse effectivement avoir
au final des propositions à faire à
chaque jeune sur la question des
contrats doctoraux alors j'imagine que
la région comme toutes les régions
d'ailleurs
l'île de france comme toutes les régions
a suivi dans le cadre d'un accord qui
avait été passée avec l'association des
régions de france
la politique mise en place à l'est par
l'état qui fait que tous les contrats
doctoraux d'état peuvent être prolongées
sur la demande des écoles doctorales et
s'est transmis au ministère et le
ministère finance aux universités ou aux
organismes de recherche enfin aux
employeurs des doctorants le nombre de
mois supplémentaires nécessaires par
apple et qui ont été générés par par
cette crise et ça peut aller jusqu'à une
année même si le confinement n'a duré
que deux mois parce que je suis
parfaitement consciente que il ya un
certain nombre de choses qui ne se mène
qu'au printemps et que donc voilà si on
n'a pas réussi à faire une campagne de
prélèvements au printemps en réalité
c'est une année complète qui perdu donc
l'état prend en charge les prolongations
des contrats doctoraux financièrement je
sais que la question avait été posée
parce que j'avais autorisé à rallonger
les contrats doctoraux évidemment on
sait qu'on avait dit que c'était gentil
il est rallongé mec je les finançait pas
vous imaginez bien que je faisais pas
rallonger sans les financer un jeu pas
complètement ciné qui non plus donc ils
ont été ils peuvent être rallongée d'une
année c'est à la demande des écoles
doctorales le ministère simplement c'est
comme un guichet quand on voit aux
établissements ce qui leur est
nécessaire pour payer cela et c'est
valable sur toutes les années de
doctorants c'est à dire que nous nous
sommes engagés jusqu'en 2022
2 de mémoire puisqu'il y compris ceux
qui démarraient leur doctorat en 19 ans
peuvent avoir besoin de financements
complémentaires
à l'issue des trois ans des trois ans de
leurs doctorants donc voilà c'est
aujourd'hui à peu près 43,8 millions
d'euros qui sont consacrés en 2020 à la
poursuite du financement de nos
doctorants et c'est bien normal et je
pense que la région ile de france
comme tout un toutes les régions se sont
engagés à faire la même chose sur leur
propre contrat puisque vous savez qu'il
ya des contrats doctoraux qui sont
financés par les régions
en ce qui concerne la création d'emplois
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont on a cette
année 700 la création de 700 emplois
nets en plus dont 315 qui concerne les
organismes de recherche et comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure et 68 millions
d'euros qui sont qui vont aller abondé
la masse salariale du cnrs 60 millions
d'euros c'est ce qui a été estimée pour
passer le fameux mur et 8 millions
d'euros supplémentaires
donc voilà de ce point de vue ce que je
pouvais vous répondrez aux sénateurs un
grès le plan 60 mais nous n'y avons pas
renoncé loin de là il y a effectivement
actuellement trente mille logements qui
sont construits où on était
ont été livrés ou sont en cours de
construction notre problème majeur c'est
le foncier et c'est pourquoi dans le
tour des régions que je fais en ce
moment je demande systématiquement aux
maires des villes universitaires ou au
président de métropole ou présidents de
communauté d'agglo de que nous puissions
regarder ensemble s'il n'ya pas du
foncier disponible pour la construction
de logements étudiants et quoi qu'il en
soit l'engagement a été pris d'avoir
l'ensemble des logements déjà existants
rénové et par exemple il ya quinze jours
de ça j'étais dans le grand est est ce
que nous avons convenu c'est que puisque
la rénovation des logements supprimer
une centaine de chambres et bien nous
allions construire 150 chambres
supplémentaires pour pouvoir à la fois
rénové et puis compenser la baisse du
nombre de chambres lits à ces
rénovations puisqu'on passe les chambres
de 9 à 13 mètres carrés dans le cadre de
ces rénovations donc voilà c'est quelque
chose évidemment laquelle je suis très
très attentive mais suffit à l'air vous
avez posé la question de de ces
officines qui prépare qui prépare soit
pour les concours d'entrée dans l'est
dans les ici soit pour
le concours de médecine alors la bonne
nouvelle si je puis dire c'est que comme
il n'y a plus de concours d'entrée dans
les ici puisque nous n'avons supprimés
et comme il n'y a plus de concours de
fin de première année en médecine
puisque nous l'avons supprimés je pense
que ces officines vont disparaître
d'elle même en tout cas c'est mon
souhait parce que effectivement vous
avez raison de le dire
c'est parfois beaucoup d'argent qui est
demandé à des familles pour un résultat
qui n'est pas toujours aussi merveilleux
que ça et notamment en ce qui concerne
la paces ce qui était bien plus efficace
c'était les étudiants de deuxième année
qui faisait du coaching cent des
étudiants de première année et qui
obtenait souvent de bien meilleurs
résultats que que les officines privées
qui qui formaient les étudiants alors ça
va me permettre d'aller directement vers
vous madame la sénatrice pour parler de
ces réformes des études de santé
en fait ce dont nous sommes convaincus
c'est que c'est parce que on fait partir
les jeunes de la région et qu'on l'est
concentre sur les villes dans lesquelles
il y a des chu pour l'heure 12 14 voir
ses années d'études que en réalité une
reviennent plus ensuite
là où ils ont grandi si je puis dire
donc en fait nous avons travaillé de
deux façons d'une part nous avons
autorisé les universités qui n'ont pas
de chu à ouvrir des licences accès santé
de manière à ce que le début des études
de médecine puisse se faire en proximité
et une sauce fasse pas obligatoirement
dans une ville avec un chu et d'autre
part dans la réforme du deuxième et du
troisième siècle nous avons certifié un
certain nombre de médecins soient des
médecins libéraux sur des médecins qui
pratiquent dans des maisons santé soit
ce sera le cas dans le dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé avec la création de
250 postes de praticiens hospitaliers
enseignants
hors chu pour que ces jeunes puissent
retourner finir leur formation ailleurs
que dans les chu il ya une période qui
doit se faire en chu sont obligatoires
pour la qualité de la formation de nos
médecins mais par contre le début des
études et la possibilité de faire des
stages dans la région dont on est
originaire ou ailleurs d'ailleurs mais
enfin en tout cas ailleurs que dans les
grands pôles universitaires avec des chu
c'est ce que nous pensons le plus
efficace ce que nous pensons aussi
efficace c'est de permettre à des
étudiants d'accéder aux études de
médecine par des voies diversifier et de
ne pas uniquement sélectionné comme
c'était fait notamment quand le concours
exister sur des disciplines très
scientifique et technologique
parce que il y à aussi dans l'exercice
de la médecine autre chose que de la
technique ou autre chose que des grandes
plates formes etc
ortuno médecin actuellement sont formés
avec des grandes plateformes avec des
technologies extrêmement ambitieuse et
intéressante bien sûr mais qui
finalement les détournent de la médecine
peut-être plus humaine où on prend plus
de temps pour échanger avec les gens
donc c'est aussi pour cela que les
licences accès santé peuvent être par
exemple des licences de philosophie
auquel on va ajouter
des modules de santé qui sont pilotés
par les facultés de médecine qui
viennent remplacer une partie la
naissance de philo et l'intérêt c'est
que on considère qu'on pourra ainsi
avoir des profils plus diversifiée dans
les futurs médecins qui seront formés et
la répartition c'est à peu près 60%
d'accès aux études de santé au travers
des ce qu'on appelle les passants les
premières années d'accès santé et 40% au
travers des licences accès santé de
manière à vraiment diversifier au
maximum les étudiants qui accéderont aux
études de santé
donc tout ça ça vient de se mettre en
place un cette rentrée donc voilà et
évidemment nous avons augmenté le nombre
de places en 2021 de manière à absorber
à la fois ce qui re doublerait
l'ancienne formule et ceux qui
rentreraient au travers de la nouvelle
formule de manière à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas de voie là parce qu'on on ne pose
pas de problème aux étudiants qui
redoublerait parce que les années de
transition sont toujours des années
compliquées
donc c'est en 2021 qu'on va voir cette
disparition en tout cas cette forte
augmentation du nombre de jeunes dans la
poursuite de leurs études de santé
pardon j'ai été un peu longue mais parce
que c'est comme c'est assez complexe en
réalité sur la question de la façon dont
s'organise finalement les projets
académiques au niveau des sites
des sites universitaires c'est avant
tout ce sont avant toute chose des
projets académiques 1 et moi ce que je
demande toutes les universités c'est de
définir leur signature et leur signature
elle se définit de deux façons elle se
définit par la qualité de la science
qu'elles font et la façon dont elles
peuvent se projeter sur leur territoire
et donc finalement oui il y a de fait un
lien avec les collectivités avec la
partie au développement économique
puisqu'une grande partie des étudiants
ont vocation à alimenter en fait en
compétences les entreprises et les
métiers localement sur les bassins
d'emploi quand on regarde en fait ce qui
se passe à l'université entre les
étudiants qui sont inscrits en première
année et puis ceux qui accèdent au
doctorat c'est une pyramide
donc évidemment il faut se soucier de
l'insertion professionnelle de tous les
autres de tous ceux qui n'arrivent pas
au sommet de la pyramide si je puis dire
mais si je peux prendre cette image donc
évidemment ça se fait en lien avec les
collectivités qui ont tout intérêt en
réalité à avoir un enseignement
supérieur et une recherche forte parce
que c'est ce qui va attirer des
entreprises qui vont venir s'installer
parce qu'elles vont pouvoir leur dire
que si elles s'installent là ils auront
des compétences des ressources humaines
des gens bien formés que l'on pourra re
former les gens dans l'université et
c'est donc ce lien entre le monde
académique et le monde universitaire se
fait de mieux en mieux et il se fait
d'autant mieux que l'on favorise par
exemple des plates formes d'innovation
partager des laboratoires qui partagent
des équipements des étudiants qui
on comme sujet de stage une question
d'innovation posée par une pme et que ça
se développe de plus en plus aussi dans
les universités millions en jetons sur
la question de la précarité étudiante en
fait il ya plusieurs mesures qui sont
prises il ya des mesures qui sont
effectivement destiné aux plus fragiles
aux étudiants boursiers notamment
on a ensuite des mesures qui concernent
l'ensemble des étudiants vous avez
remarqué qu effectivement le ticket à 1
euro va se poursuivre sur l'année 2021
évidemment mon souhait c'est que il
puisse se poursuivre parce que c'est
quand même très important cette question
d'alimentation et d'alimentation
équilibrée pour pour les étudiants les
plus fragiles
il ya évidemment ce fait de l'aide
supplémentaire de 150 euros et le gel
des droits d'inscription pour tout le
monde le gel des loyers pour tout le
monde le gel du prix du ticket resto u
pour tout le monde et puis nous sommes
en train de travailler à la question des
jobs étudiants parce qu'en fait on se
rend compte que les étudiants sont là
aussi très pénalisé parce qu'il n'ya
plus de petits jobs entre guillemets
dans cette conjoncture un peu
particulière et on regarde comment on
peut faciliter le fait qu'ils aient des
petits jobs au sein des établissements
des crous des bibliothèques
universitaires etc et enfin pour
terminer je reviens vers vous madame la
sénatrice
il n'y a pas du tout de mélange entre le
contrat de plan état région et le plan
de relance le plan de relance ça vient
s'ajouter au contrat de plan état région
et ce que je voulais dire c'est que
comme nous avons demandé voir apparaître
dans le plan de relance tout ce qui
était susceptible de démarrer dès
janvier 2021
il ya des choses qui étaient
initialement des projets qui étaient
initialement soumis au contrat de plan
et qui du coup vont être soumis au plan
de relance et plus au contrat de plan
mais c'est des enveloppes totalement
différente c'est pas du tout me cible on
va pas dire que ce qu'on a financé dans
le plan de relance
on financera pas dans le contrat de plan
c des enveloppes distinctes ça va
permettre de faire beaucoup plus de
projets en réalité et puis le contrat de
plan état région ou de projets état
région mais je crois que ses revenus
revenus plan enfin il me semble c'est
pas que de la rénovation thermique
alors que dans le cadre du plan de
relance est vraiment la partie
rénovation rénovation thermique
le contrat de plan il est
il prévoit notamment un focus la
rénovation des locaux liés à la santé la
question de la transition numérique
elle sonde adaptation des locaux de ce
point de vue là et puis effectivement
des logements sociaux
tout ce qui faisait partie de la
rénovation thermique va pouvoir être
financés en plus si je puis dire au
travers du plan de relance
voilà pour cette audition de la ministre
frédéric vidal sur le budget de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche pour l'année 2000 21
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez revoir tous
nos programmes sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite une très
bonne journée sur public sénat
[Musique]